[THEME MUSIC]
MATT GAUNT: So you're presenting
at I/O this year, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
MATT GAUNT: I have one
bit of advice for you
that was given to me
by, um, Paul Irish.
So when I first did a
rehearsal for my I/O talk,
everything was, like, OK-- got
some feedback on how to make it
better, all the rest of it.
And Paul Irish kind of
gave me one bit of advice.
And he quoted me.
He was just like, when
you introduce yourself,
you should have said,
"Hi, I'm Matt Gaunt."
And, no.
It was, "Hi, I'm,
um, Matt Gaunt."
He was just like,
don't-- it's your name.
You know your name.
You don't need to
think about it.
ADDY OSMANI: Do you
realize that when
you were talking
about Paul Irish,
you called him "um, Paul Irish"?
MATT GAUNT: Yes!
So that's what
I'm talking about.
I can't do names.
So the minute I got
onstage at I/O--
ADDY OSMANI: In your head, is
"um" just the same as, like,
"Mr." or "Mrs." or "Dr."?
MATT GAUNT: Yes.
If that was on the drop-down,
I could type that in, actually.
I'd totally do that.
"Um Matt Gaunt."
ADDY OSMANI: There we go.
We should have introduced
that into the standard.
MATT GAUNT: Anyway, that's
my one bit of advice.
Because I got onstage
at I/O, and that
was the first thing I had to
say, was introduce my name,
and I actually went, "Hi,
my name's, um, Matt Gaunt."
And then, instantly, I
was just like, dammit!
I'd been onstage literally
no longer than 10 seconds,
and I've already messed it up.
So there.
There you go.
ADDY OSMANI: OK.
I'll be sure to
follow that advice.
MATT GAUNT: If you
say "um" now, you're
also going to get that
mental monologue of me
telling that entire story.
ADDY OSMANI: I'm already
worrying about this.
MATT GAUNT: Good.
Do you have any
tips for promises?
ADDY OSMANI: Um, yes I do.
MATT GAUNT: I see what you
did there, and I like it.
Because I'm using them
for ServiceWorker and push
notifications, and
it's the first time
I've really been using
promises extensively.
Especially with
push, you get really
quite deep nested promises.
I'm kind of getting
a bit lost when
it comes to debugging them.
I was just wondering
if you had any tips.
Because, at the moment, DevTools
is just not helping that much.
ADDY OSMANI: OK, sure.
So I could show you
something if you like.
We've been recently working on
trying to improve visualizing
the promise flow in DevTools.
MATT GAUNT: OK.
ADDY OSMANI: And something
you're probably used to using
is console logs or the debugger
statements to debug promises.
But we've got a
new Promises panel.
And the idea here--
MATT GAUNT: Under
the little draw thing
that I frickin' hate?
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
And the idea here is
similar to the timeline.
Just start recording,
and then any
promises they start getting
pulled inside your scripts
will get visualized here.
So here we've got some
promises that started off
in a gray Pending state, and
then they turned green as soon
as they were resolved.
MATT GAUNT: So that's
like the good case?
It's like the dot,
then everything's fine?
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
You can also see what lines
those promises were defined on.
You can just click to jump
straight through to the code
where they were define,
which is kind of useful.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: You can also see
where the promises settled
and jump to the line
of code for those.
And you get to see the time it
took to settle those promises.
MATT GAUNT: OK.
Nice.
I imagine the time to settle is
particularly useful with things
like Fetch, where you're
doing a number of requests,
and all that kind of stuff.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, exactly.
So here's another demo
where, basically, I've
got a promise that's going to
be rejecting intentionally,
just so I can show you this.
So here, these are
actually showing up in red.
So green is Resolved, red is
Rejected, and gray is Pending.
MATT GAUNT: Someone
missed a trick
with not going for just,
like, amber while they're not
settled or rejected.
ADDY OSMANI: That seems
like a great patch
you could write and submit.
MATT GAUNT: I won't.
I don't love it that much,
but someone missed a trick.
ADDY OSMANI: All
right, all right.
So another thing
we've got in place
here is, like,
let's say you've got
a whole ton of different
promises in your page.
You're finding it hard to
locate a particular one.
We've got something
for filtering down
based on different promise
states, so Pending or Fulfilled
or Rejected.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
So that's the same as
console, where you'd normally
just search for text in the
filter box-- this is actually
just based on state?
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
And then we've got this
little magical async checkbox.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, I was going
to say, that doesn't make sense,
because promises
are async by nature.
ADDY OSMANI: Well,
let me show you
why we've got that check box.
So here I've got an
app that basically
is going to go and pull
in a new news story
every couple of seconds.
And I'm just going and
setting a break point
at that point where I'm
attending the content
of the article to the DOM.
So we're just going to go,
and we're going to do that.
And if we take a look
at the callstacks
here, what you'll notice
is that there's not
a lot of information.
It's not helping us visualize
the asynchronous control flow,
what's going on in our app.
MATT GAUNT: That's
almost useless.
ADDY OSMANI: It's
It pretty much is useless.
So what we're going to do
here is we're going to go
and we're going to check
the async check box.
If you click inside
the Promises panel,
it's just going to sync up
with the normal async debugging
n in DevTools.
We're going to redo
this demo once again.
What you'll now see is we've
got this nice rich whole set
of asynchronous call
stacks being displayed.
A lot more
information this time.
We can see where
promises are resolving;
we can see XHR requests; we
can see promise resolutions
for other parts of the app.
And we can even go and see
what line of code to find them.
So we can just go and
click, and, as you'll see,
the line directly in your
source get highlighted too.
MATT GAUNT: So this is basically
like the promise [INAUDIBLE],
every single method that's kind
of gone through and resulted
in other promises
getting [INAUDIBLE].
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
In fact, we can just go and
see an entire flow right there.
MATT GAUNT: You can actually
see all of the nested promises
as they get called and
see how deep it goes.
Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: And this
is a little bit better
than just using console logging.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
So why not have the async
option always checked?
ADDY OSMANI: I don't have
a right answer for this,
but I think it might just be
due to the computational cost
of having async turned
on all the time.
MATT GAUNT: Just having to
track everything all the time,
rather than just track
the result states.
Nice.
So this is a video from
your jQuery UK talk?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
I recently gave this
talk at jQuery UK
called "DevTools
State of the Union,"
which kind of walks
through a performance case
study and a grab bag
of new tips-- things
you can do in the DevTools.
MATT GAUNT: A little
birdie told me
that you had to be
escorted offstage.
ADDY OSMANI: What?
I never get escorted off
the stage for any reason!
MATT GAUNT: How long was
the talk that you gave?
ADDY OSMANI: So my
talk was supposed
to be 30 minutes long, right?
And I timed it.
I didn't really get that
much sleep that night.
Made sure it was 30 minutes.
MATT GAUNT: How
long was the talk?
Come on, Addy.
ADDY OSMANI: It was 34?
And 1/2?
MATT GAUNT: How long
would it have taken?
ADDY OSMANI: 30-- if my
slides hadn't crashed!
MATT GAUNT: Yeah,
but how long would it
have taken you to finish before
they kicked you offstage?
ADDY OSMANI: A little
longer than 30 minutes?
Maybe?
MATT GAUNT: 40?
50?
ADDY OSMANI: Who knows, really?
[LAUGHTER]
ADDY OSMANI: It's one
of life's mysteries.
[THEME MUSIC]